ستبدو الأمور مختلفة كثيرًا
في المرة القادمة التي تذهب فيها إلى المطار
أولاً وقبل كل شيء سيكون أقل ازدحامًا
، ومن المؤكد أن هناك احتياطات معينة
في مكانها مثل زجاجي عند العدادات
التي تخبر الناس بها أن يحافظوا على
مسافاتهم عندما يتماشون معهم في أغلب الأحيان
يقوم الأشخاص بذلك بالفعل ولكن لا
تنسَ وضع بطاقة الصعود إلى الطائرة على هاتفك
في وقت مبكر ، فأسطح أقل للمس ،
ترى بطاقة الهوية الخاصة بك
، حاول واحسب عدد الأسطح التي
تلمسها خلال العملية برمتها ،
شيء واحد أريد أن أعرضه لك  كيف
أحزم أمامي في الوقت الحاضر ، لقد حصلوا على معقم يدي ،
لقد رأيت عدد الأسطح التي لمستها لتوي ،
هذا عندما أقوم بغسل القليل من
معقم اليدين باستمرار ،
يغادر هذا القطار
أحد المخاوف الكبيرة
دائمًا هو تلك الأنواع من القطارات  ركوب الخيل في الوقت
الحالي ، الأمور ليست بهذا الازدحام ولكن مع
بدء المطارات في الالتقاط ، قد تحتاج إلى
الكثير من الوقت الإضافي حتى تتمكن من المشي
إلى الردهة بدلاً من الركوب ،
سيقرر الجميع ما إذا كان من المنطقي أم لا
إنه نوع من المخاطر
والمكافآت ، وهو شيء سأقوله
لكم وهو أن فصل أنفسكم عن بعضنا البعض أمر
مهم بشكل واضح ،
ولكن فكر في مدة
الرحلات الأقصر سيكون من الواضح أنه سيكون أفضل ،
كما يقولون إن الطائرة قد تم
تعقيمها
قبل أن نحصل عليها بالفعل  عند استخدام
عملية التعقيم الكهروستاتيكي هذه الآن
عندما تصل إلى صفك ، هناك بعض الأشياء
التي يجب وضعها في الاعتبار أولاً ، حاول أولاً ولمس أقل
عدد ممكن من الأسطح عندما
أجلس ، سأحاول بالفعل اختيار
مقعد بجوار النافذة والسبب في ذلك
سيكون لدي اتصال أقل مع الأشخاص
الذين يمشون بجوار الممر ، فأنا أمضي
قدمًا وأقوم بتشغيل ما يسمى
جاسبر هنا وتقوم برفعها إلى أعلى مستوى
ممكن مما يتسبب في بعض
تدفق الهواء المضطرب أمامك و
ربما تفكك أي سحب من الفيروسات ،
فهذه أشياء صغيرة قد تحدث
فرقًا بسيطًا ولكن من السهل القيام
بها وربما يستحق الأمر ذلك
[موسيقى]